hey Stephanie Hillier Ron White here and  thanks for playing our game and joining  the Ron's Raj and participating in our  contest it means a lot to us  and congratulations on your decision to  be a professional stand-up comedian  it's a ballsy choice and I wish you the  best of luck  I've also played it to Johnny Carson  Theatre and Nebraska and a very special  place and listen I just want the best  for you and and and go out there and get  them stay focused be yourself that's the  truth be true to your nature and you  will you'll go places in this business  anyway thanks for thanks for joining the  entourage and I see you around soon I  hope  you